Tenteren is totally pandan, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's
good.
It's a music producer who composes the departure melody. I
think that if you make more than 110 stations with the departure melody alone, you can make more than 200 for 2 minutes
.
[Applause]
[Music]
Played as a keyboard player in a band called Cassiopeia for 35 years.  Because it's
a synthesizer that is also a keyboard, it
was a very difficult performance when I spit out the powder like this.
Boo Boo
[Music]
of times to do do
Go or o n ms word Plains depature Prism User
good work Posing in  love this work this
war
[Music]
Of course, the sound that is easy to hear is important. I think it's a
departure melody.
But in my case, I took a bell-shaped one
[music]
I think I painted it almost all the time.
[Music] On
the Tozai Line Tokyo Meter's subway, listening to the reflection mail between the first and last stations on the Tozai Line
will make you feel like you're going to get hired.
[Music]
There is also an area of old Tokyo, where you eat, it's like a town, this is a little like a town, and t
e one that the student wants to see next time is the young gener
tion  This is Bailey Secret Omi, but it's a little musical.
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
FEFE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE FE
It's never been so honored to be able to make a train melody. It's never
been so happy to hear my own sound on my favorite railroad
[Music]
Yeah Yeah